Oh, good morning church.
Good morning. Thank you. This half.
My name is Dan Leaphart.
I'm an elder here at Henderson Hills
and it's so good to be with you this morning.
It's so good to be able to bring God's word
to you this morning, not why we're here to worship him.
Thank you to the worship team
and wow, what a privilege it is to be able
to preach for the first time, uh, here today.
So before I open God's word, though,
I have a question for you.
May sound a little odd, but it's a simple question
and it's this, where are you?
Where are you now? I see you sitting there.
So I don't mean physically. Where are you?
I mean, really, where are you?
Um, have you ever been in a conversation with somebody
and though they're just a couple of feet away, you can tell
after a while maybe they're not really there,
they're somewhere else.
It's probably never happened to you before.
I'm sure it hasn't. Uh,
but you've been told
that you can't be in two places at the same time.
But that just isn't true, is it?
See, we're often in two places
or more than one place at any given time.
The reason for that is we're more than just a physical body.
Jesus even alluded to this in Matthew 15,
verse eight, quoting Isaiah.
He says, this, people honors me with their lips,
but their heart is what far from me?
So we can be in more than one place at at any given time.
So I'll ask you again now that we were onto this.
Where are you today?
Now, when you wanna measure the distance
between two objects, you might get a tape measure
or something like this to measure that distance.
But how do you tell the distance?
How do you measure the distance between two hearts?
How do you measure the distance
between your heart and God's heart?
We're going to open God's word
and we're going to look for clues as to where
certain people are in their relation to God.
And then we're gonna bring it back and we're gonna try
and determine where we are in our relation to God.
So turn with me now to one Samuel 26.
That's where we're gonna be reading from today.
If you've been tracking along in this series on one Samuel
and the life of David,
you'll know we're nearing the end of the book.
Saul is presently king in Israel
and his spiritual
and his political, uh,
life at this point is in decline, right?
We've seen that over the last several chapters.
David has been anointed king,
but he's presently on the run from Saul who's seeking
to kill him to take his life.
So we're gonna pick it up here in one Samuel 26.
I'm gonna read the whole chapter for us
and then we are gonna come back and dive in.
So one Samuel 26, then the Z fights came
to Saul at Gibbon saying is not David hiding himself on the
hill of Haah, which is on the east of Jeon.
So Saul arose and went down to the wilderness of Ziff
with 3000 chosen men of Israel
to seek David in the wilderness of Ziff.
And Saul camped on the hill of Haah, which is
beside the road on the east of Jeon.
But David remained in the wilderness when he saw
that Saul had came after him into the wilderness.
David sent out spies and learned that Saul had indeed come.
Then David Rose
and came to the place where Saul had encamped
and David Sa, the place where Saul Lay
and Abner the son of Ner and the commander of his army.
Saul was lying within the encampment while the army
was encamped around him.
Then David said to a Alek, the Hittite,
and to Joe Abs brother Abishai, the son of Aya
who will go down with me into the camp to Saul
and Abishai said, I will go down with you.
So David and Abishai went to the army by night and Saul
and their lay Saul sleeping within the encampment
with his spear stuck in the ground at his head and Abner
and the army lay around him.
Then Abishai said to David,
God has given your enemy into your hand this day.
Now please let me pin him to the earth with one stroke
of the spear and I will not strike twice.
But David said to Abishai, do not destroy him for
who can put out his hand against the Lord's
anointed and be guiltless.
And David said, as the Lord lives, the Lord will strike him,
or his day will come to die,
or he will go down into battle and perish.
The Lord forbid that I should put out my hand against the
Lord's anointed, but take now the spear that is at his head
and the jar of water and let us go.
So David took the spear
and the jar of water from Saul's head and they went away.
No man saw it or knew it,
nor did any awake for they were all asleep
because a deep sleep from the Lord had fallen upon them.
Then David went over to the other side
and stood far off on the top of a hill with a great space
between them and David called to the army
and to Abner, the son of nurse saying,
will you not answer Abner?
Then Abner answered, who are you who calls to the king?
And David said to Abner, are you not a man
who was like you in Israel?
Why then have you not kept watch over your Lord the king,
for one of the people came in to destroy the king your Lord,
this thing which you have not,
which you have done is not good as the Lord lives,
you deserve to die because you have not kept watch over your
Lord the Lord's anointed
and now see where the king's spear is
and the jar of water that was at his head.
Saul recognized David's voice
and said, is this your voice, my son David?
And David said, it is my voice, my Lord oh king.
And he said, why does my Lord pursue after his servant?
For what have I done?
What evil is on my hands now
therefore, let my Lord the king hear
the words of his servant.
If it is the Lord who has stirred you up against me,
may he accept an offering.
But if it is men, may they be cursed before the Lord.
For they have driven me out this day
that I should have no share in the heritage
of the Lord saying, go serve other gods
now therefore, let not my blood fall
to the earth away from the presence of the Lord.
For the king of Israel has come out to seek a single flea
like one who hunts a partridge in the mountains.
Then Saul said, I have sinned.
Return my son David for I will no more. Do you harm?
Because my life was precious in your eyes this day,
behold I have acted foolishly and have made a great mistake.
And David answered and said, here is the Spiro King.
Let one of the young men come over and take it.
The Lord rewards every man for his righteousness
and his faithfulness for the Lord gave you into my hand
today and I would not put out my hand against the Lord's
anointed Behold,
as your life was precious this day in my sight.
So may my life be precious in the sight of the Lord
and may he deliver me out of all tribulation.
Then Saul said to David, blessed be you my son David.
You will do many things and will succeed in them.
So David went his way and Saul returned to his place.
So if you look in the ESV,
there's a chapter heading that says David spares Saul
again, seems like we've been here before, haven't we?
If you remember two chapters ago
that chapter heading said, David spares Saul's life,
and now here is the sequel to that story.
So that while there are similarities,
I think we'll find fresh application here in chapter 26.
Verses one to five really set the stage for us.
David must not have learned that the Z fights were not
as friends stay away from the Z fights,
David, they're not your friends.
So the Z fights again rat out David to Saul
and this time Saul brings an army of 3000 men.
Okay? That's the setting that we're in here in chapter 26.
If your Bible has cross references, you may see
a little cross-reference in verse one that points you
to one Samuel 2319.
That's the very first encounter with the Phis
where they first rat out David to Saul.
But you also may see a little cross reference
to Psalm 54.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna go to Psalm 54,
turn there with me if you will
keep a finger in one Samuel 26.
We're gonna come back to that,
but we're gonna use this psalm
to determine David's proximity to God
and then we're gonna come back into this passage
and find it being applied.
Okay? So this this, this sermon is really about finding
your position before God.
Okay? So we're gonna find David's position before God
and we're gonna do it in Psalm 54.
Now textually Psalm 54
probably goes better with the first encounter
with the Z fights in one Samuel 23.
But I'm gonna propose to you that it's the same Z fights
ratting out the same David to the same Saul,
and I believe it speaks to the same heart
of David in a very, very similar situation.
So let's go to first, uh, or sorry to Psalm 54
and we're gonna look at this and we're gonna go through it
and we're gonna take note of where David is.
So if you look at the title in Psalm 54, it says
to the choir master with stringed instruments, a masque
of David when the zip fights went
and told Saul, is not David hiding among us?
Okay? But let's look at verse one.
Oh God, save me by your name
and vindicate me by your might.
Now I get why David is crying out
to God saying, save me in this situation,
but why does he mention his name?
Why would he mention his name in this verse?
So we're gonna bring up a a little bit
of a technical note here before we dive in.
Any farther biblical names lots
of times have significant meaning, okay?
And in the original language,
but in the English it often gets lost in translation
including the names of God.
So we're going to go through this
and we're gonna look through it, the names of God.
But first we need
to know a little bit about the original language.
The Old Testament was originally written in Hebrew,
not not English, it was written in Hebrew.
And the book of Psalms is uh,
poetry Hebrew poetry.
Hebrew poetry is both very beautiful
and very memorable, okay?
It often takes the form of two lines
or couplets and it there's a line A and a line B.
And line B relates to line A in any one
of a number of different ways.
It can either be, uh, line B can either build upon line A,
line B can either be synonymous
or parallel in thought to line A,
or it could be a consequence of line A
or it could be the opposite, et cetera.
So when we look at verse one, What do we see?
We see that it's a parallel thought.
Save me in line A is parallel to vindicate me in line B.
And your name in line A is parallel to what
your might David sees
might in God's name
he sees and he knows that there's power to save
in God's name.
All right, church, we're gonna have a little fun now we're
gonna go through Psalm 54
and if you like to mark up your Bibles
and I hope that you do get out a pen or a pencil
or a highlighter or little sticky tabs or whatever you do.
And we're gonna go through this psalm,
this short Psalm only seven verses,
and we're gonna look for the names of God
and how they're used, because I believe it carries great
significance to understanding where David is in this moment
as Saul is hunting him down.
Our first name of God is right in verse one,
it's the word God, our English word God, God.
In the Hebrew is
Elohim Elohim.
Elohim speaks to the almighty,
majestic creator God.
In the beginning, Elohim created the heavens and the earth.
Elohim is the almighty, majestic creator God.
And when you see the word God in the Old Testament,
it's almost always this Hebrew word Elohim.
We see Elohim again in verse two and in verse three.
But what I want to do is jump down to verse four.
Verse four says, behold God is my helper.
The Lord is the upholder of my life.
Notice that God is parallel to Lord.
And this word Lord is written
as you normally would write the word Lord as a capital L
and a lowercase ORD.
When you see the word Lord written in that format,
it's the Hebrew word Adonai Adonai.
Adonai is the typical Hebrew word for Lord or master
or owner Lord,
master owner.
So let's read this in with what we know
so far about these names.
It says, behold, Elohim is my helper.
Let that sink in for just one moment.
Church, as we interpret this, Elohim, the almighty,
majestic creator, God
is my
helper, he's my helper.
David understood he's my helper, but he is more than that.
He's my Adonai, my Lord, my master
and how he helps is in the form
of upholding my life to
His life was in the master's hand
in completely in the master's hand.
Do you see that parallel there?
So let's go on to verse five.
In verse five, No names of God,
but we see a positional shift in David.
Notice in the first part of this, in line A,
we see third person pronouns.
He's speaking to us and he says He, who's he?
The Adonai, my Lord, my master.
He will return the evil to my enemies.
But look at line B.
Now, there's a shift from talking about God to now
standing and gazing directly at God
in the second person pronouns
in your faithfulness put an end to them.
David shifts his gaze directly towards God
and he invites us to do the same
in this situation.
Now let's look at verse six, with a free will offering,
I will sacrifice to you and the parallel.
Line B says, I will give thanks to your name.
Oh Lord, for it is good.
There's that word, Lord, again.
But notice it looks differently than the Lord did in
verse four, doesn't it?
This Lord is in all caps
When we see the Lord in all capital letters in the Old
Testament, it's the divine personal name
of God best rendered
Yahweh, Yahweh.
Now it's debated exactly
what the word Yahweh means.
Lots of times people will say it's related
or derived from the Hebrew verb hayah, which is
to be to exist.
And certainly there's an element of that in the name.
When I've been studying the names of God, the definition
that I've arrived at, I'm gonna share with you,
hopefully it'll be helpful to you, that Yahweh
is the ever present, intimate
saving one, the ever present, intimate
saving one that sounds like a God who's near, doesn't it?
He's near. David even writes later in Psalm 1 45, 18,
Yahweh is near to all who call on him
and building on that line B says to all who call on him.
In truth, one Bible dictionary that I have states this
to call on the name of Yahweh is to confess
and to be ready for encounter with this person
and to be ready for encounter with this person.
And that begs the question today, church,
why are you here today?
Why are you here today?
And if I polled everybody, I'm sure we would get lots
of different answers to that question.
But Did you come here today
to encounter God?
I hope that you did. I hope that that is the driving reason.
I pray that's the driving reason of why you are here today.
You see in David the process
of encountering God in this psalm, don't we?
We saw the positional change his usage of his name
as he draws close to God, calling on his name.
All this, keep in mind the situation.
We're gonna flip back to one Samuel 26 here
and you can start turning back here to to one Samuel 26.
But notice the situation that he's in.
He's drawing near to God, calling on his name
and he's near to him.
In this situation where Saul is trying to take his life,
encountering God should change us,
it should change our perspective.
It certainly changed David.
So back in one Samuel 26,
we're gonna pick it up here in verse six, where we left off
after getting a lay of the land, David calls two men over
and he asks for somebody to go with him into Saul's camp.
He calls a him elect to hit tight.
We never hear from him again.
And he calls also Abishai, the son of Aya.
It mentions Joe Abs brother here.
This is the first mention of Abishai.
A little bit about him as he volunteers to go
with David into Saul's camp.
Abishai is actually David's nephew, he's the son
of of David's sister Zaya.
Uh, one resource I've got calls him a fiercely
loyal warrior.
And I think sometimes to a fault he's often a
thorn in David's side.
But let's go with David
and Abishai now into Saul's camp.
Imagine, imagine this, you see,
you come upon in a circle of an army,
3000 men strong
and they're all lying there fast asleep in a circle.
And you can see Saul in the middle of this.
So we're gonna go, we're gonna walk with him.
We're gonna step over all of these sleeping soldiers
and your adrenaline is
rushing, you're sweating.
And abishai is the first to get there to Saul.
And what does he do? What does he say in verse eight?
Let me pin him to the ground.
I will not need to strike him twice. I love that line.
What a great line. I will not strike him twice.
But notice how he invokes the name
of God in this situation.
He says, God has given your enemy into your hand this day.
He invokes, he invokes
Elohim, the Almighty creator God, in this moment
he has given your enemy into your hands.
Hold on to that for a moment.
We'll determine where Abishai is in his relation
to God with those clues.
But notice what David says in verse nine.
He rebuts do not destroy him
and he calls Saul the Lord's anointed in verse nine.
You see that? And that's our word
Lord, but which Lord is it?
It's in all capital letters, isn't it?
Yahweh, Yahweh.
He is Yahweh's anointed.
Notice the name change from Elohim to Yahweh.
We can mark up our Bibles all over the
Old Testament with the names of God.
It's actually a really fun thing to do.
If you have the the the goal to go do that.
You can do it anywhere in the Old Testament,
you can do it back here in one Samuel 26.
What you'll see is that the name Yahweh
actually shows up in this chapter 16
times every single time.
It's coming from the mouth of David every single time.
I think it's a major, major clue.
The main point here is that David was close to God
and he completely entrusted this situation to his God.
He knew that Saul would die, he knew he would become king,
but Saul was Yahweh's anointed
and Yahweh was gonna take care of him.
Not him, though he knew the end. He did not know the means.
Look at verse 10. He says, Yahweh will strike him
or his day will come to die or he will go down to battle
and perish.
For all David knew Saul could have died of old age.
That was not his concern.
He knew the means though did not involve abishai
pinning him to the ground.
But throughout world history, we know that many,
many thrones have been taken by by bloodshed.
It would not have been abnormal for David to take it here.
In fact, it was abnormal for him not to take it here.
In fact, Saul in their last encounter told him in in chapter
24, verse 19, if a man finds his enemy,
will he let him go away safe?
That answer's no. It's not normal to do that.
You see, it's normal to take matters into our own hands.
Maybe you even believe
that God is giving you the opportunity to do so.
Have you ever heard the the statement,
the end justifies the means?
Ever heard that very common?
Let me ask a question, is that true?
Think about that for just a moment while I propose to you
that it that is practically almost never true.
As Christians, what we do matters,
but how we do it also matters, right?
Maybe it's lying on that resume to get that dream job.
We file that under embellishing.
But when does embellishing become an outright lie?
And maybe it's throwing coworkers under the bus
and lying
and shameless self-promotion
to get ahead in the corporate world, maybe to rise
to the top of the corporate ladder.
Or maybe it's lowering your
standards and sacrificing your morals
to find love, to speed up that process
and find that potential future spouse
rather than wait for God to work his plan out in our lives.
We often want to take things into our own hands
to speed that process up.
Because you know, waiting on God is hard.
Waiting on God is difficult. It's painful.
And in the culture today around us, it's getting more
and more difficult as we have this pressure, for instance,
satisfaction, don't we?
The end does not justify the means.
And David knew that he was resolved
to let Yahweh handle Yahweh's own matters.
He would take care of Saul.
David knew the end and the means were fuzzy,
but he knew it would not come about
by him sinning against his God.
So in verse 12, we're gonna back up.
We're gonna take Saul's spear and his water jug
and we're gonna leave this encampment.
Amazingly, nobody wakes up.
They lie, still asleep.
Imagine how that would've seemed to David
and Abishai to know that God's sovereignty allowed for
God to put them into a deep sleep
while they got the spear and while they left.
And in verse 13, it tells us that David
and Abishai went far off to the top of a hill
with a great space between them.
This great space is a great physical space,
but I'll propose to you that it is very symbolic of a great
spiritual distance between them.
If David is near to Yahweh
and Saul is far from David,
where do you think Saul is in his relation to God?
Very far. Very far.
And we've seen Saul moving farther
and farther away over the last several
chapters, have we not?
So David calls over and Saul replies in verse 17.
Is this your voice? My son David? Notice the familial term.
My son David is having nothing to do with the fake proximity
that Saul offers up.
He simply replies my Lord o king.
While Saul is far from God, there can be no commonality
between David and Saul.
After all, David's biggest complaint in Saul chasing him
is in verse 19.
He says, they have GI driven me out this day
that I should have no share in the heritage
of Yahweh saying go serve other gods.
Did you catch that there are no other gods?
David cared more about being driven from Yahweh's heritage
than he did for his own life.
He even writes in Psalm 63, 3,
and I love the way the new Living translation puts it.
He says, your unfailing love is better than life itself.
How I praise you.
Does that speak like your heart today?
Does that thought resonate within your heart?
That his unfailing love is more
to you than your very life?
Even in Saul's relentless pursuit of David's life,
David rested near to God.
So they depart
Saul and David depart and they never meet again.
In verse 25, Saul's last words
to David are you will do many things and succeed in them.
As the chapter closes, Yahweh continues to be on the heart
and the mind and the lips of David.
While Saul's over here getting his wisdom from fortune
cookies, He never
even mentions the name of God once in this chapter.
So where is Saul?
Where is David and where are you?
Well, how can we tell? Remember our last two
verses in Psalm 54 verses six
and seven, directing his gaze to Yahweh
with a free will offering, I will sacrifice to you.
I will give thanks to your name. Oh, Yahweh for it is good.
Why? For he has delivered me from every trouble
and my eye has looked in triumph on my enemies.
How did he get to that point?
He didn't know how it would go down,
but he was so sure of God's will.
And isn't that the question we often ask?
How do I know God's will? How do I know God's will?
Well, I would submit to you
that first step is knowing God.
Knowing God. Maybe you're here today
and you didn't even know that God was knowable
or that he's a near God who wants
to have personal relationships with people.
Well, I'll tell you some good news.
He is knowable and having a relationship
with him is possible,
but not on our own means it's only
through his son Jesus Christ.
You see, it's our sin which puts immeasurable distance
between us so that we cannot come to him.
But he provided that way for us.
He came to us, his son, Jesus came and took our sin
and took that death penalty that we deserved in our place.
So that by faith, by trusting, believing in him,
we can have eternal life and we can truly know him.
But for the believers who are here today,
we are then able also to draw closer to him and move nearer
and nearer to him as well.
Now, there's two biblical words which I want to share
with you that get the point across.
They're not in our text, but conceptually they talk about
how we can know God in in different ways.
The first is the Greek word oda.
OIDA.
Oda speaks to a perceived or deduced
or a reasoned knowledge.
It's intellectual, perceived deduced
reasoned knowledge.
Remember Abishai, he knew Elohim,
he knew God, he knew David would be king,
and Saul had to die.
So in a sense he knew God's will.
But from a distance to abishai, we could say that God
was the man upstairs.
Have you ever heard that? The man upstairs.
Have you ever said that?
I would propose to you that as Christians we ought not
to say that about God,
but we should never, ever, ever think
that for two reasons.
First of all, the Bible doesn't portray him that way.
He portrays, they portray God as near and present
and active in our lives and in the world around us.
But the second reason is established very early in the
scripture in Genesis four, seven B.
It says this, sin is crouching at the door
and this desire is for you, but you must master it.
That's the danger in placing distance between us and God.
Are you living your life today? Like he's the man upstairs.
Is he distant? Do we go to him when we need something
or when we're in a bind?
That just isn't the way God is portrayed in the Bible
and the invitation is to draw near to him
and know him better.
And that leads us to the second word.
That second word is the Greek word gco. Gco.
It's an experienced knowledge.
It's an experiential knowledge.
It speaks of one who is close to God's heart.
David had that intimate knowledge
of God in Psalm 25, 4 and five.
He writes, make me know your way.
So Yahweh, teach me your path.
Lead me in your truth and teach me for you
or the God of my salvation for you.
I wait all the day long. Make me know your ways.
That's that same. It's the Hebrew equivalent
to the word ginosko.
And later Solomon,
his son would famously write in Proverbs three, six,
in all your ways, acknowledge him.
That's that same word in all your ways. Know him.
Know him, KNOW, him
and he will make straight your paths.
The making straight of your paths is God's will
revealed to you in your life.
So those paths,
they may not be easy, they may not be glamorous,
they may not even be obvious.
So church, we wait.
We wait like David all the day long and maybe the day
after that and maybe the day after that.
But when we know him, as David knew him, we're near to him
as he was near to him,
and we can experience as we encounter God, we can experience
that he is sufficient
and he is satisfying in that waiting.
And we can, like David offer up the free will offering
of our life to him
and give thanks to him knowing that he is good.
Is that the way you know God?
Is that the way you know God? Where are you today? Church?
Yes.